ils sont parmi les meilleurs et les
mieux entraînées du monde ils sont
roumains américains et britanniques ce
matin ils naviguent dans les eaux
troubles et brumeuse de la mer noire au
large de constanta en roumanie l'ukraine
n'est qu'à 150 km h
leur mission sauver ce navire au loin
occupés par des insurgés qui ont
perturbé le commerce maritime en europe
le scénario effectifs évidemment mais le
simuler comme ils le font ne jamais été
aussi importants pour tester la
coordination des alliés de l'otan
c'est une valse de précision entre des
soldats qui ne se connaissent pas où
l'erreur n'est pas permise surtout pas
avec les tensions qui manque la région
l'hélicoptère arrive justement d'un de
ces exercices en mer noire c'est le
genre d'entraînement qui de routine pour
les forces de l'otan mais avec le risque
d'un conflit direct avec la russie qui
augmente les bases comme celle ci à
constanta en roumanie ont été mises en
état d' alerte
et chaque jour au moins trois avions de
combat comme sétif on décolle de la base
de comptes en deçà pour répondre à une
situation anormale avant que la guerre
commence ça n'arrive qu'une fois par
semaine dit l'officier pas griffé
[Musique]
l'île des serpents la voici pas plus
grande que deux terrains de football
elle est devenue un des territoires les
plus disputées dans la guerre entre la
russie et l'ukraine constamment prise
pour cible par les tirs de l'armée russe
le temps la surveille elle n'est qu'à 45
km d oruma
[Musique]
les risques de débordements sont réels
ils sortent anders sandholm complexe et
loin de tout débat la bécasse evry pc
salimou fofana
et pas juste en roumanie des soldats et
des appareils de combat se sont ajoutés
sur la plupart des bases militaires de
l'otan à titre de dissuasion
les canadiens débarqueront ici sous peu
pour s'entraîner à leur tour alors que
le temps est confronté à l'un de ses
plus grands défis en 72 ans d'existence
ici tu as marre altérait secours aide au
canada à constanta en roumanie